this is amazing
so first of all I would like to thank
Shaun Guthrie and his whole team for
making this one week being like the most
amazing week of my life
thanks to Hector and thanks to David and
Brian and James and Stephanie and Mary
you are amazing and thanks to all of the
other students can congrats to all of us
guys it's so great to be here with you
thank you
thanks to my professor mr. andreas kuba
who's with us today for supporting me
believing in me believing in this film
and of course submitting it to this
festival and thanks to the University of
television and film in Munich it's great
to be a part of that University thank
you for that University that's amazing
thanks to all of my teammates who made
this film really really possible who did
an amazing job for it thanks to the
headlamp light my pretty my producer
who's here today and thanks to my God my
beloved cinematographer who is here
today such a pleasure working with you
guys I can't thank you enough really
thank you very much thanks to my
wonderful actors public finger was here
today and especially Dmitri shot who's
my lead actor my he's like just
everything he's my lead actor my
co-writer and my best friend and the man
I admire the most yeah who hurt me the
idea he knocked us he keeps I wouldn't
be anywhere without my parents I just
really wouldn't be anywhere without my
parents
thank you so much for being here for
joining me spasibo bombs as reasonably
regarded in yeah especially was Lewiston
thanks to my beloved fiance who's made
with me today for being the toughest
woman that I know and they benefit Lee
starts off the Phyllis was too let's
Niaga shaft test would rejoice again
based on us to verse to fear and managed
businesses on lovely see in doctor fume
and of course thanks to the Academy for
voting from a movie for inviting me to
this wonderful place and just making a
dream come true and this evening and
this this this ceremony and this whole
week and this thing here will change a
lot of things and I will oh that to you
for the rest of my life so thank you